er kann schweigen angesichts dieser
bilder aus dem krieg angela merkel hat
es lange getan obwohl ihr viele
vorwarfen viel zu lange viel zu
nachsichtig mit russland gewesen zu sein
entschuldigen wir sich merkel dafür aber
nicht machte sie jetzt bei ihrem ersten
großen auftritt seit ihrem ausscheiden
aus dem amt deutlich
sie ist eine der berühmtesten frauen der
welt doch seit angela merkel nicht mehr
bundeskanzlerin ist ist sie praktisch
abgetaucht jetzt nach sechs monaten
stille bricht sie ihr schweigen endlich
ich bin im rückblick wenn ich über alle
summiere eigentlich froh dass ich mir
nicht vorwerfen muss ich habe es zu
wenig versucht mit ein ein solches
ereignis wie es jetzt stattgefunden hat
zu verhindern 16 jahre im epizentrum der
macht und dann wie verschwunden
allenfalls urlaubs und freizeit fotos
kursierten von der dauer kanzlerin was
fehlte klare kante gegen putins
angriffskrieg zwar ließ sie ausrichten
die bilder aus der ukraine seien
barbarisch doch viele deutsche fragten
sich wo ist die frau die uns so lang
anführte und wenn ich dann lese ja
das kenne ich schon als eine schelte
betreiben aber wohl fühlt hermine
merkels leicht sich zurück und macht
jetzt nur noch wohl viele termine da sag
ja
[Applaus]
zur erinnerung merkel und putin hatten
über jahre auf augenhöhe miteinander
gearbeitet
sie setzt auf das prinzip frieden durch
handel russland durch gas und
energielieferungen an deutschland zu
binden sei ein friedensgarant das hatte
merkel immer gesagt ich meine wir reden
hier über russland russland ist die
zweitgrößte atommacht der welt russland
ist territorial ein riesen gebilde von
asien bis europa und auch wenn man den
europäischen teil nimmt eines der
größten länder europas und die bleiben
existieren also es ist eine große trauer
dass es nicht gelungen ist aber ich
mache mir jetzt keine vorwürfe dass ich
es versucht habe auch nach der
völkerrechtswidrigen invasion der krim
im jahr 2014 hielt sie den
gesprächskanal offen wir wollen putin
nicht demütigen wird sie zitiert ob das
richtig war zweifelhaft gestern abend
brach merkel endlich ihr schweigen und
ich hatte dann auch noch in meinen
letzten amtstagen
wir haben mit vielen in europa darüber
geredet also es war schon eine brenzlige
situation und dann war ja noch die
bundespräsidentenwahl vorher und da war
es ja auch schon ganz offensichtlich und
dann der habe ich ja auch teilgenommen
und da konnte ich mich auch nochmal kurz
mit verschiedenen leuten austauschen
also das war schon klar dass man das
sehr sehr ernst nehmen muss was da
stattfand und dann habe ich natürlich
den besuch von olaf scholz noch in
moskau verfolgt und die duma
anstrengungen dort den republiken da die
vermeintlichen separatisten du kannst du
hans grundmann jetzt dass sie du mal den
wunsch hat dass die selbstständig werden
oder sogar ja und das habe ich also
schon alles minutiös verfolgt und mir
war schon klar dass da etwas nicht gutes
passiert putin war ja nun auch in
besonderer weise
sozusagen man sie kennt ja noch die
langen tische und die tests und heute
keinen sehen war bei cam g20 treffen
persönlich dabei also dass auch sehr
sehr vorsichtig aber
das nutzt ja alles nichts das kann man
sagen kann sein kann nicht sein dass
eine reine spekulation das was passiert
ist ist aus meiner sicht
nicht also nicht nicht nur nicht
akzeptabel sondern eben einfach von
russland seite ein großer fehler jetzt
lassen was bei der subjektiven bewertung
weg ist ein objektiver bruch aller
völkerrechtlichen regelungen und all
dessen was uns in europa überhaupt in
frieden zusammenleben lässt wenn wir
anfangen durch jahrhunderte zu gehen und
sagen welches stück territorium gehört
wie dann haben wir nur noch krieg das
geht auf gar keinen fall ich habe es
glücklicherweise
ausreichend versucht
mit dem französischen jeweiligen
französischen präsidenten zusammen und
das gibt mir jedenfalls eine gewisse
beruhigung ich würde mich sehr schlecht
fühlen wenn man gesagt hat auch mit dem
man braucht gar nicht zu reden der ist
sowieso ich bin bundeskanzlerin ade ich
bin keine ganz normale bürgerin so und
jetzt ist meine hoffnung
nach wie vor ich suche ja noch nach
meinem weg was ist eine bundeskanzlerin
die ja so also unsere bundeskanzlerin
ehemaligen bundeskanzlerin angela merkel
und nur wenige journalisten in
deutschland kennen angela merkel und ihr
wirken besser als unser bild
parlamentsbüro chef ralf schuler er hat
sie auch zahllose dienst reichen
begleitet war sogar mit ihrem weißen
hauses jetzt bei uns hier im studio
verschlüsselung morgen reist du hast
jetzt diesen auftritt ja gestern auch
live vor ort miterlebt wie ist der
einzuordnen sie hat sich ja eben
monatelang gar nicht geäußert und jetzt
eben das also sie hatten davon
gesprochen dass sie sich jetzt nur noch
wohlfühlt termine aussucht das war
definitiv einer und das zeigt so ein
bisschen dass sie um ihr erbe ringt und
sich die termine so aussucht dass sie
ein podium hat um zu erklären warum sie
alles richtig gemacht hat dass kann man
menschlich wahrscheinlich niemandem
verdenken dass man jetzt nicht
öffentlich mit sich selbst hat eine
kritische bestandsaufnahme war es ganz
gewiss nicht und wenn man ein moderator
hat der zu anfang sagt meine kanzlerin
wird sich immer bleiben also sich als
fan outet dann ist auch keine grillparty
zu erwarten dort journalistisch gesehen
es war insofern interessant als dass sie
entspannt da war sie war lockerer sie
hat nicht mehr so viel zu verlieren sie
muss nicht taktisch überlegen ob sie
damit irgendeinen flanke auf
machtpolitisch weder international noch
national das hat sozusagen den privaten
bereich also ich war fünf wochen an der
ostsee und habe da hörbücher gehört das
hätte sie früher allenfalls in
wahlkämpfen funktional angesteuert das
hat sie jetzt freimütig erzählt und das
publikum war auch eine fanschar die
extra deshalb gekommen ist absolvierte
war sehr geneigt
politisch war es eher sagen wir mal
interessant als aufklären auf welche
wunden punkte hätte man denn besonders
eingehen müssen und wie hat sie sich
positioniert zu ihrer russlandpolitik in
den vergangenen das ist ja das
interessante also sie hat eine technik
angewandt die sich schon im amt gern
benutzt hat es gibt die frage welche
verantwortung haben sie denn für das
desaster der russland politik
und dann sagt sie also ich habe großes
vertrauen in die bundesregierung und die
machen das schon ganz gut das war nicht
die frage und beim zweiten anlauf sagt
sie dann ich muss mir wenigstens nicht
vorwerfen zu wenig getan zu haben und es
nicht wenigstens versucht zu haben das
war auch nicht die frage das hat er gar
keiner vorgeworfen also zu antworten auf
einen vorwurf der nicht existiert ist
immer ganz interessant die entscheidende
frage ist warum hat es nicht
funktioniert und da war der moderator
leider ein totalausfall sie hat an
anderer stelle gesagt putin versteht nur
härte ja und genau das hat sie all die
jahre ihm eben nicht gegeben sie hat
eigentlich immer versucht ihn irgendwie
zu einem deal zu gewinnen und diesen
bunten punkt hätte man sicherlich weiter
herausarbeiten müssen kam aber überhaupt
nicht würdest du denn sagen aus deiner
sicht hätte sie sich gerade bei solchen
themen deutlicher entschuldigen müssen
oder muss ihre politik im kontext von
damals der etwas milderer bewertet
werden also entschuldigung dass ich
regierende die 16 jahre im amt waren und
die weltpolitik mitgeprägt haben in den
staub werfen das wäre glaube ich nicht
realistisch so etwas zu verlangen das
ist er also die japanische art wo man
sich dann öffentlich demütigt und bis
zum boden verbeugt so etwas ist bei uns
nicht üblich aber man hätte schon eine
kritische bestandsaufnahme erwarten
können das ist aber auch typisch merkel
sie lässt an der fassade keinen riss zu
keinen kratzer sie macht auch keinen auf
das soll so nicht passieren und sie ist
glaube ich auch tatsächlich davon
überzeugt dass sie das getan hat was
getan werden musste und leider damit
nicht erfolgreich war aber das möchte
sich so schmerzhaft nicht ausbreiten der
erste große auftritt der alt kanzlerin
ralf schuler vielen herzlichen dank für
deinen besuch im studio